[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter
voldemort and horcruxes more
specifically
we're going to be taking a look at why
harry should not be considered as a
horcrux
jk rowling who coined horcrux defines
them as
a receptacle prepared by dark magic in
which a dark wizard
has intentionally hidden a fragment of
his soul for the purpose of attaining
immortality
essentially they are soul containers
objects onto which the dark wizard or
witch in question
have successfully imparted a piece of
themselves
in the harry potter books voldemort ends
up being the second wizard to ever
successfully produce one
except he produces more than one he
produces
six seven only if you count harry which
is what i'm going to dig into
further these horcruxes were the diary
the ring
the locket the diadem the cub and nagini
because harry carried a piece of
voldemort's soul with him
many believe that harry 2 was a horcrux
but i'm here to set the record straight
harry potter was not a horcrux
but don't worry i've got evidence to
back up these flagrant claims
let me start off with an important quote
from an interview
with jk rowling here's the thing for
convenience i had doubled or say to
harry you were the horcrux he never
meant to make
but i think by definition a horcrux has
to be made intentionally
so because voldemort never went through
the grotesque
process that i imagine creates a horcrux
with harry
it was just that he had destabilized his
soul so much
that it split when he was hit by the
backfiring curse
and so this part of it flies off and
attaches to the only living thing in the
room
a part of it flees in the very close to
death limbo state
that voldemort then goes on and exists
in i suppose
it's very close to being a horcrux but
harry did not become an evil object
he didn't have curses upon him that the
other horcruxes had
he himself was not contaminated by
carrying this bit of parasitic soul
essentially what this quote explains is
that harry isn't a horcrux because he
simply wasn't made
by the traditional horcrux creation
process yes
he carried a piece of voldemort's soul
but he wasn't a dark object
nor were there any curses afflicting him
i will say this
harry was very close to horcrux about as
close to horcrux that you can get
but that doesn't mean he was one when
voldemort fired his killing curse at
baby harry
and was hit with it after it backfired
it took its toll on him
his soul had been destabilized so much
that
all it took was a backfiring curse to
make it split once more
his soul freshly split detached itself
from voldemort
and ended up attaching itself to the
only other living thing in the room
harry did you guys know this let me know
in the comment section
below if you enjoy the content please
like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time happiness can be found
even in the darkest of times if only one
remembers to turn
on the light
[Music]
you